[Música]
obrigado
boa tarde tudo bom bom bom eu vou falar
pra vocês sobre o trabalho na era
digital né a revolução do pelo coral
colaborativa e como está impactando a
vida das pessoas pensa que você um
desafio muito grande desafio de salvar
vidas néon um grupo de cientistas tinham
desafio de resolver é o formato de
enzima do hiv e eles tinham as melhores
cabeças e recursos suficientes para
fazer isso
passou um ano eles não conseguiram dois
três quatro cinco anos os recursos sendo
consumidos seis anos e nada 7 nada 8
nada 10 anos e eles não conseguiram
decifrar o formato daquela enzima para
poder fazer os remédios e tudo mais
no final da sua apresentação vou mostrar
pra vocês como ele resolver o desafio
dez anos depois o mundo mudou
a concorrência acirrada dinâmica muito
acelerada de inovação ter o custo
interno das empresas de equipe dentro
das empresas é cada vez mais caro e
obviamente a crise econômica tudo isso
impactou nas nossas vidas e na forma
como a gente trabalha na forma como a
gente faz os nossos projetos em pega os
nossos desafios como era antigamente a
gente tinha um projeto e tinha uma
equipe interna caro e leva muito tempo
três fatores impactaram e mudaram
completamente como isso funcionava o
surgimento da internet
as ferramentas se tornaram cada vez mais
acessíveis e o surgimento das
comunidades fizeram que todas as coisas
se espalhassem eficaz em dinâmicas muito
mais rapidamente como que ficou agora a
gente tem um projeto desafio para ser
resolvido ea gente pode usar a
comunidade a cabeça da população inteira
para resolver esse problema
com isso a gente diminui o investimento
e
diminuir o tempo de resolução desses
problemas
a tecnologia mudou a forma como a gente
compra coisas se relaciona planejar
nossas férias e arruma trabalho e isso
tudo a gente tem que pensar de uma forma
como fazer isso da melhor forma possível
pra agente absorver e ter um resultado
positivo e muitas vezes a gente dá mole
com isso e nesse dentro desse cenário
surge o crowd sourcing o crowd sourcing
literalmente nem uma palavra é criado
pelo chef o wii é o ato de você pegar um
trabalho tradicionalmente feito por uma
pessoa internamente e você jogar para
pessoas externas fora do seu time dentro
de uma chamada aberta pega suas palavras
chaves aqui o clube só se você pega um
trabalho pode ser feito por qualquer
pessoa joga um grupo indefinido para o
mercado em uma chamada aberta agora como
que a gente pode fazer isso na prática
todos conhecem o linux é um sistema
operacional concorrente da microsoft que
foi completamente desenvolvido por
pessoas diferentes em seus lugares em
suas casas
wikipédia todos vocês conhecem quando
surgiu foi um alvoroço é todo mundo ia
no ficar burro todo mundo aprender
coisas erradas
depois a gente viu que um sistema bem
feito formado por pessoas e hierarquia
moderação você consegue criar uma
biblioteca uma enciclopédia muito mais
rica do que todas se copel já criadas
antes
agora será que a gente consegue fazer
isso e ganhar dinheiro com isso com essa
nova forma de você fazer as coisas com
essa nova dinâmica da internet com essas
duas ações são ações gratuitas nas
pessoas fizeram para ter reconhecimento
e não para ganhar dinheiro e aí tem a
plataforma inocente uma plataforma
global onde é cientistas do mundo
inteiro pesquisadores geólogos as
empresas podem chegar lá e botar um
desafio muito grande por exemplo o real
pode ter um super desafio pra fazer um
agente químico para o xampu e eles não
conseguiram fazer internamente eles
colocam esse desafio nessa plataforma e
outros pessoas comuns ou não podem
chegar lá e ganhar 5
mil dólares 100 mil dólares 200 mil
dólares é para resolver aquele problema
para quem fotógrafo tem essa plataforma
a istockphoto que revolucionou o mercado
de fotografia global o mercado de
bilhões
os caras conseguiram dominar 90 por
cento desse mercado você pode chegar lá
tirar sua foto e venderá o seu trabalho
online
eu lancei essa plataforma dez anos atrás
que é o do lobos onde designers e
criativos do mundo inteiro podem chegar
lá e também vender a sua solução para
pequenos empreendedores e para quem acha
que isso é só pra área criativa ou
científica se você for programador
advogado quiser fazer atendimento ao
cliente você também pode fazer através
desta plataforma é que também tem
alcance global
então você vê que tem soluções que você
pode arrumar trabalho resolver problemas
e desafios em todas as áreas usando a
internet
agora as empresas começaram a isso como
uma forma também de engarrafamentos nas
empresas estão querendo criar links com
os seus consumidores de uma forma e
estão usando a inteligência colaborativa
para atrair esses consumidores e vender
cada vez mais voltar aqui
a dell por exemplo lançou essa
plataforma onde todos os consumidores
podem dar sugestões de melhoria de
produtos e os próprios consumidores
podem lá votar no que é melhor do que
não é
e eles vão criando um backlog de de
melhorias
a fiat lançou a plataforma com mais de 2
milhões de interações dos consumidores
para criar um carro conceito baseado no
que é no feedback de todos os usuários
né ele de fato lançar um carro é claro
que é um carro conceito mas lançaram no
último verão
agora como eu faço isso no meu dia a dia
aqui está um pouco de forma tardia
apesar do seu design é porque
compreendeu aqui mas como que a gente
resolve os problemas do nosso dia a dia
com uma base de inteligência
colaborativa a gente tem dois tipos de
desafios que a gente pode usar um
desafio base de idéias ou seja preciso
desenvolver novos produtos novos sabores
por exemplo a rússia lançou
alguns anos atrás é o desafio de quem
criar sabores diferentes países lançarem
tiveram três selecionados e de fato foi
para a rua vender bastante então você
tem base de idéias e outra solução são
base é de mão de obra e essa mão de obra
pode ser especializado ou não então você
consegue hoje validar perfil é de
facebook o perfil de plataformas usando
alguém simplesmente vendo aquela aquele
perfil tá tá certo ou não então não sei
se alguém especializado ou pode ser um
cientista então precisa ter alguém é que
conheço aquela dinâmica e depois que
você já sabe qual o tipo de base de mão
de obra que vai vai utilizar
você precisa ingerir esses colaboradores
então é muito importante você ter quatro
pacientes um deles é você ter a star é
faz bem detalhadas
então é muito importante dizer o que
você quer e o que você quer que seja
executado
você precisa dar feedback constante
porque é isso que vai direcionar os
participantes um ambiente de comunicação
precisa ser 100% é fluido neto você tem
um ambiente informal de comunicação
direta e franca com todos os seus
colaboradores com essa comunidade é
muito importante e por último você
precisa ter regras claras e pra isso
entra a moderação que é fundamental
então você definiu a base você já sabe
como gerir essa comunidade e agora você
precisa motivar estas pessoas
uma dessas formas é você utilizar um
prêmio em dinheiro então isso atrai
muitas pessoas no caso do arroz o cara
ganhava dinheiro encanta me ligava o
reconhecimento que é a segunda forma de
você motivar as pessoas né você é
entregar o reconhecimento àquela pessoa
fazer parte de alguma coisa maior
é muito importante você alguns
colaboradores do linux
eles se sentem orgulhosos de terem
participado de um projeto global eo
então isso é muito importante isso faz
com que as pessoas venham para o seu
projecto e obviamente isso como eu falei
antes empresas que querem criar
engajamento você cria não se você quer
relacionamento com essas pessoas nem
sempre ela já conheciam a sua empresa é
mas elas podem se tornar a seus clientes
e utilizar os seus produtos e como você
sabe se você
o resultado do que vem para da
comunidade está adequado está correto tá
do jeito que você imaginava
você pode você deve usar madeiras e essa
moderação pode ser de três formas pode
ter moderação da sua própria empresa
pode ser uma alteração feita pelos
usuários
ou pode ser uma moderação feita pro meu
próprio cliente no caso do edu lobo e
quando a gente joga lá pra comunidade de
designers executar a tarefa
a gente usa duas dessas formas a própria
comunidade de designers verifica se
aquele trabalho está sendo um plágio é
um trabalho legal não é então o que
tiver cué fugindo das regras
os designers denunciam e automaticamente
aquele usuário está fora eo próprio
cliente depois que vê todos os outros
trabalhos ele escolhe o que mais agrada
ele então a moderação em qualquer
trabalho colaborativo de comunidade é
fundamental pra você ter um resultado é
satisfatório e aí a gente chega pro pro
final desse total que eu queria falar
pra vocês que é como que aqueles
cientistas resolveram aquele problema de
depois de dez anos
gastar a fortuna de dinheiro e dinheiro
praticamente acaba
eles conseguiram desenvolver e achar o
formato da enzima para eles poderem
fabricar o remédio ele pegar aquele
desafio jogaram na internet fizeram um
jogo online um passou e em três semanas
foi é concluído o diagnóstico a o
formato da enzima que ele estava
procurando
o que eles não fizeram em dez anos em
três semanas usando a inteligência
colaborativa não especializada seja as
pessoas estavam lá jogando e aquele
joguinho foi dando a resolução daquele
problema então finalizo com a frase do
do professor michael usem que a
comunidade certa com os incentivos
adequados é capaz de inventar escrever e
conduzir iniciativas de pesquisa e
negócios com maior eficiência eo menor
custo do que uma empresa tradicional
muito obrigado